CHINA, YOU SAY THERE WILL BE
REPERCUSSIONS FOR PELOSI'S
VISIT.
WE'RE ALSO SEEING A BLOCKADE OF
SORTS AROUND TAIWAN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WE'LL SEE?
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK THAT
PRESIDENT XI AT THE END OF THE
DAY REALLY WANTS TO PROVOKE
CONFLICT HERE.
HIS WORDS SEEM TO INDICATE THAT
HE'S NOT OUT TO PICK A FIGHT IN
RESPONSE TO THIS ACTION THAT HAS
TAKEN PLACE, WHICH HAS BEEN
AWKWARD TO SAY THE LEAST,
PARTICULARLY IN WASHINGTON.
WHERE YOU HAVE THE PRESIDENT AND
NATIONAL SECURITY MILITARY
REPORTEDLY DISCOURAGING THIS,
THE SPEAKER GOING AHEAD, OTHERS
SAYING IT IS THE SPEAKER'S RIGHT
AND IT IS.
THE TIMING OF THIS IS VERY
DIFFICULT IN PARTICULAR BECAUSE
PRESIDENT XI, LET'S REMEMBER, HE
IS IN ELECTION SEASON AS WELL.
HE'S THREE MONTHS AWAY FROM THE
GATHERING OF THE COMMUNIST
PARTY, WHICH WILL PRESUMABLY
RE-ELECT HIM FOR AN
UNPRECEDENTED THIRD TERM, THAT
WILL BE FOLLOWED BY RE-ELECTION
OF THE PRESIDENT AND THE HEAD OF
THE MILITARY COMMISSION.
HE WANTED A SMOOTH PATH TO THIS,
THIS PARTICULAR TRIP AT THIS
TIME AND IN THIS WAY REALLY DOES
FORCE HIM TO BE AN ULTRA
NATIONALIST.
HE HAS TO SHOW HE'S TOUGHER THAN
ALL THE REST.
YOU WILL SEE LIVE FIRE EXERCISES
ALL AROUND THE ISLAND OF TAIWAN,
YOU'LL SEE AIRCRAFT BACK INTO
THE AIR SPACE AND SO FORTH, ALL
OF THIS, I THINK, WE WILL SEE,
AND I WOULD SUSPECT THIS MAY
PLAY OUT OVER SOME TIME AS WELL.
THIS WILL NOT JUST BE, YOU KNOW,
A SPASM OF ACTIVITY RIGHT NOW.
THERE COULD BE FURTHER
REPERCUSSIONS DOWN THE LINE.
THERE ARE ALSO SOME ECONOMIC
SANCTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN POSED
ON TAIWAN AS A RESULT OF THIS AS
WELL.
THIS WILL TAKE SOME TIME TO PLAY
OUT.
I DON'T SEE CONFLICT RIGHT NOW,
I DON'T THINK THAT'S IN HIS OR
CHINA'S INTEREST.
BUT WE CLEARLY HAVE POSITIONED
OUR FORCES AND OUR CAPABILITIES
SO THAT WE CAN DO WHAT IS
NECESSARY IF IT COMES TO THAT.
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI AND HER
DELEGATION WERE SEEN LEAVING
TAIWAN'S CAPITAL.
PELOSI GAVE A POWERFUL SPEECH,
SHE MADE IT CLEAR THAT THE U.S.
STANDS IN SUPPORT OF THE
SELF-GOVERNING ISLAND.
CHINA IS CALLING PELOSI'S VISIT
TO TAIWAN A, QUOTE, COMPLETE
FARCE AND RESPONDED WITH PLANS
FOR MILITARY EXERCISES AROUND
THE ISLAND.
CNN'S WILL RIPLEY IS LIVE IN THE
TAIWANESE CAPITAL, ALSO JOINING
US IS CNN NATIONAL SECURITY
ANALYST BETH SANER.
WILL, WHAT IS THE LATEST FROM
THERE ON WHAT HAS BEEN SUCH AN
ANTICIPATED VISIT ALL AROUND?
>> WELL, THERE'S TWO DIFFERENT
STORY LINES WE HAVE BEEN
FOLLOWING, ONE OF COURSE IS
NANCY PELOSI MAKING THIS
HISTORIC TRIP, GIVING A SPEECH
ABOUT DEMOCRACY AND FRIENDSHIP
AND SOLIDARITY WITH TAIWAN AND
MEETING WITH -- YOU KNOW, FROM
POLITICAL LEADERS TO BUSINESS
LEADERS LIKE THE CHIP
MANUFACTURER, VISITING SITES
THAT ARE SIGNIFICANT
HISTORICALLY HERE, BUT THEN JUST
LITERALLY JUST MILES OFF OF THE
COAST OF TAIWAN YOU HAVE THE
CHINESE MILITARY ASSEMBLING AT
SIX DIFFERENT LOCATIONS AROUND
THE ISLAND AND THESE EXERCISES,
YOU KNOW, TAIWANESE OFFICIALS
HAVE BASICALLY CALLED IT
TANTAMOUNT TO ALMOST A BLOCKADE
OR A PRACTICE FOR A BLOCKADE TO
TRY TO STOP SUPPLIES FROM COMING
INTO THE TAIWAN, IF THERE WERE
SOME SORT OF A MILITARY CONFLICT
A BLOCKADE IS THE FIRST THING
THAT YOU WOULD SEE AS A WARNING
SIGN HERE SO TRYING TO
ESSENTIALLY SIMULATING THAT AND
NOW AS A RESULT TAIWAN IS
RENEGOTIATING AIR TRAVEL ROUTES,
TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO GET
PLANES THROUGH THE PHILIPPINES
OR JAPAN INSTEAD OF TRYING TO
FLY OVER THE CHINESE MILITARY.
NANCY PELOSI'S PLANE ACTUALLY
HAD TO TAKE A THREE-HOUR DETOUR
ARRIVING HERE TO AVOID THE SOUTH
CHINA SEA AND TO AVOID HEAVILY
MILITARIZED AREAS SHE MAY HAVE
TO FLY OVER.
THIS IS SERIOUS BUSINESS.
EVEN VESSELS ARE BEING REROUTED
AS A RESULT OF THIS.
I THINK THE CRUCIAL THING TO
WATCH NOW, BRIANNA, IS WHAT
HAPPENS NOW THAT NANCY PELOSI'S
PLANE HAS LEFT, WHAT DOES CHINA
DO NOW.
THIS IS THE TIME THAT THESE
EXERCISES ARE REALLY DUE TO KICK
OFF IN LARGE SCALE.
>> BETH, THAT'S WHERE I WANT TO
TAKE THIS FOR YOUR ANALYSIS.
WE'VE HAD PAST SPEAKERS OF THE
HOUSE VISIT TAIWAN N APRIL WE
HAD A BIPARTISAN SENATE
DELEGATION VISIT TAIWAN BUT
CLEARLY THE REACTION TO NANCY
PELOSI'S VISIT IS DIFFERENT,
SHE'S BEEN A LONG-TIME CRITIC OF
THE REGIME IN BEIJING BUT WHAT
IS YOUR TAKE ON THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT OF MILITARY
EXERCISES AND ENCIRCLING OF THE
SIGH LAND THAT WILL JUST
DESCRIBED?
>> I THINK WE HAVE TO TAKE THIS
AND PUT THIS INTO A BROADER
CONTEXT.
ON ONE HAND THIS IS DEFINITELY
ABOUT SPEAKER PELOSI'S VISIT AND
THE FACT THAT SHE'S SUCH A
HIGH-RANKING OFFICIAL, SHE'S
PART OF BIDEN'S PARTY, SHE AND
OTHERS CAN'T SEPARATE WHAT SHE'S
DOING FROM US JUST POKING A
FINGER IN THEIR EYE, BUT THE
BIGGER CONTEXT HERE IS THAT THIS
IS ABOUT U.S.-CHINA RELATIONS
BEING AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
BARREL, IT IS ABOUT CHINA-TAIWAN
RELATIONS AND THOSE ARE GOING
NOWHERE, THE IDEA OF A PEACEFUL
RESOLUTION TO UNIFICATION LOOKS
FAR AND -- YOU KNOW, FARTHER
THAN IT'S EVER BEEN AND THE FACT
THAT CHINA ITSELF ISN'T DOING
VERY WELL IN THE YEAR THAT SHE
WAS SUPPOSED TO HAVE HIS BEST
YEAR EVER.
SO THERE'S A BIGGER CONTEXT HERE
AND IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT PELOSI'S
VISIT.
>> DO YOU THINK, BETH, THIS IS
GOING TO CHANGE HOW U.S.
OFFICIALS ARE APPROACHING
VISITS, ARE APPROACHING OUTREACH
GOING FORWARD?
WHEN THEY LOOK AT THIS PRETTY
OVERWHELMING RESPONSE, PRETTY
DRAMATIC RESPONSE THAT WE'RE
SEEING FROM CHINA.
>> I THINK THAT WE WILL HAVE TO
CALIBRATE.
I MEAN, I THINK ABOUT U.S.
VISITS AND U.S. MEETINGS.
THESE ARE INSTRUMENTS OF POWER
AND SO, YOU KNOW, WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS THAT WE HAVE TO BE VERY
CALIBRATED IN HOW WE USE THESE
THINGS AND UNDERSTAND THE
CONSEQUENCES, NOT THAT WE SHOULD
AVOID WHAT WE WANT TO DO, BUT
THAT WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND AND
DO IT PURPOSEFULLY.
>> IT'S A VERY, VERY INTERESTING
POINT THERE AND WE WILL HAVE TO
SEE IF THAT'S HOW THEY PROCEED
GOING FORWARD BECAUSE EVERY
SISITY CERTAINLY CHINA IS
APPROACHING THIS AS SORT OF A
POKE IN THE EYE AS YOU SAID.
BETH, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OUR THANKS TO WILL AS WELL.
>>> AND EMOTIONAL TESTIMONY IN
THE CASE AGAINST ALEX JONES.
A SANDY HOOK MOM SAYS SHE